well good evening from London actually
good eating from a gridlocked London
it's taken me one hour and 45 minutes to
travel four miles
from West London to another part of West
London because of all the strikes 600
000 workers apparently were out today uh
when does this end when does the misery
for all those who aren't striking who
don't want Barrel loads more cash in the
middle of a cost of living crisis when
does this stop when can normal people
get back to work and go to work no it
won't take them three days to get home I
just asked the question because it's
incredibly annoying if the strikers
think that we're all ending our day
after days like this thinking you know
what you must do go out and support the
strikers they're living in Cloud Cuckoo
Land
anyway that's off my chest it's been a
torrid week for those who insist at
Council culture either doesn't matter or
doesn't exist first Gary lenica was
mobbed and then suspended for his
opinions about the government's migrant
policy next Fiona Bruce was denounced as
an apologist for domestic violence over
this
for a change I'm not I I'm not blaming
Boris Johnson or Stanley Johnson
actually can he was a wife beater
Stanley Johnson on record
um okay let me just let me just
interview I'm not I'm not disputing what
we're saying but just so everyone knows
what this is referring to so Sally
Johnson's uh wife spoke to a journalist
Tom bar and she said that Stanley
Johnson had broken her nose and she'd
end up in hospital as a result Stanley
Johnson has not commented publicly on
that friends of his have said it did
happen it was a one-off yes but it did
happen
well that was it Fiona Bruce was
directed to read a prepared statement
for legal reasons this kind of thing
happens all the time by the way in live
television I'll occasionally have
something I have to read which is just
part of what you do as a live news
presenter if you think someone's going
to make an inflammatory statement you
have something which can counter it it's
called you know being fair being
reasonable about these things Jenna
Bruce didn't pass judgment she didn't
give a personal opinion she read a BBC
statement of context on legal advice
that she was directed to do but the
righteous mob don't care about the
nuances of these things members of
parliament said that she was disgraceful
petitions circular demanding should be
fired outraged keyboard Warriors
described a sickening this is Fiona
Bruce we're talking about
and refuge the domestic violence charity
the Fiona Bruce are represented with
distinction for 25 years dropped her
like a rock
with both Fiona Bruce and Gary Unica the
reaction was hysterical but entirely
predictable
ridiculous overreactions to words and
opinions have become the norm in our
society step out of line one word out of
line You'll Be vilified shamed and
censored until there are consequences
till you get canceled ruined
athletic approved it doesn't matter if
your left wing right wing white black
old Young Rich or poor and as Jeremy
Clarkson proved in the aftermath of his
amphissid joke about Meghan Markle
doesn't make any difference if you issue
a groveling series of apologies the mob
doesn't care and nor do the people who
get the apologies Megan and Harry loved
it but in that case apologize for
everything else you've ever said in
written was their response my question
is simply this do we actually want to
live in this kind of world
a world in which everybody has to walk
around with their buttocks clenched in
Terror of being castigated for something
they've said or written of losing their
their job their livelihood their
reputation a world where Fiona Brews and
trust me on this one of the nicest and
most respected people in the news
business on British television
is absurdly condemned as some kind of
wicked pariah
we used to talk about 15 minutes of fame
that was the Andy Warhol thing no
everyone gets there 15 Minutes of Shame
and the lucky ones survive it many don't
and I make no apology for loudly and
repeatedly calling out this madness for
what it is well joining me now has
talked to the contributor Esther Krakow
writer and commentator Larissa Kennedy
and domestic abuse Survivor Rachel
Williams let me start with you Rachel
Williams
I was led to believe by the howling mob
that anyone who'd suffered domestic
abuse who watched question time was
traumatized by what happened that they
watched what Fiona Bruce said and felt
instant trauma over what they themselves
had gone through did you feel that
I did not Pierce and I can honestly
agree with you that Fiona Bruce is a
great advocate for the cause um I was
fortunate to meet Fiona Bruce at
Buckingham Palace last year and she gave
me a big hug and I could tell she was
really supported of the cause and I
think she's just been absolutely
crucified
um on social media and in the press for
a repeating a comment that somebody else
had made right and the truth is from a
legal perspective if you're a journalist
you have the allegations that were made
by Stanley Johnson's uh ex-wife which
appeared in this book and he's never
responded publicly he's just given his
version through friends and that's what
she was summarizing as a right of reply
because what else could she possibly do
and for that she had to give up a 25
year role as an ambassador for Refuge I
think I think Shane's Refuge frankly let
me go now to Larissa Kennedy Larissa do
you really feel that Fiona Bruce
had to be treated this way
I think when we're talking about how
people are being treated Fiona Bruce
herself chose to step down from this
role given the response from both
beneficiaries of refuge and from other
you know people who have experienced
domestic violence but also other forms
of gendered violence who felt hurt by
the comment and that's not to say that
this is some sort of canceling or
whatever we want to call it it's rather
to say that you know I I take pride in
this role but I also mean that with when
coming with pride comes responsibility
what did she do wrong
okay let's unpack it even if you believe
her
correct in the fact that she had to
allow a Rite of reply I think no one
would have had an issue up until the
point in the sentence of which she said
it was a one-off because the framing
itself
implies some sort of diminishing of
these she did
hang on on that point on that point
Fiona Bruce didn't say it was a one-off
she said that is what friends of Stanley
Johnson have said by way a response
which by the way is entirely well hang
on hang on we don't want to hear this
let me finish That's What Friends of
Stanley Johnson have told people that's
been the only response he's given she
was actually she was accurately giving
the other side of this she wasn't saying
that is true or that is my opinion she
was simply giving a legal right to reply
because that's what we do in this
business
which I was about to acknowledge and say
that actually I think the
act and who gave it to her to say
because in fact not acknowledging that
there would be backlash from stating it
in that way is ridiculous I don't know
how anyone can work in this business and
not understand that for someone to say
one-off sounds as though you're calling
anyone or form of violence when it comes
to gender violence and domestic abuse
let me unpack what you've just said
here's the point I don't know the answer
nor does Fiona Bruce we don't know how
many times Stanley Johnson may or may
not have hit his wife right all we know
is what she has said and he's not
responded publicly other than to tell
people off the Record through friends it
was a one-off that might be true we
don't know it's it's a journalist's job
to try and find out but short of
actually having hard evidence to
corroborate that she did what I think
any news journalist would do in that
situation and simply gave the other side
from his point of view and said that
he's told people it was a one-off that
is the situation that we know about now
that may be lies and he might have been
a repeat offender and certainly his his
wife said that but we don't know that
for for a fact why should we act as
judge and jury against Stanley Johnson
in that circumstance I'm curious
we shouldn't but the phrase one-off
implies some sort of judgment there
because as you said but it wasn't Fiona
Bruce that said it someone had appears
if I had hit you with my car and I
hadn't made a public statement statement
about it and someone else had said oh
but it's only a one-off would you feel
comfortable that the implication is that
they are I'm not someone who goes around
hitting people in my car and that's a
far less serious form of abuse that
we're talking and far less emotive in
many cases it's about being cautious
with language and this isn't about
canceling it's about saying I'm going to
take a step back from this have a little
think about how I approach this in
future that isn't what happened that
isn't what happened what happened is
that refugees hang on let me finish
Refuge who she'd worked for for 25 years
and we've just heard from Rachel that
Fiona meant this and this was a cause
important to her that she dedicated 25
years of her life to promoting a charity
that combating domestic violence nobody
would do would want to do less to
trivialize this issue than Fiona Bruce
she's proved that over 25 years and she
read out a short statement on legal
advice simply giving the other side from
what Stanley Johnson had told people was
his position about what his wife had
said and for that she's had to leave
Refuge as an ambassador and they dumped
her to the walls in a statement which I
thought was was shatteringly cowardly
and pathetic let me go to Esther
here's my problem with this it's the
Glee with which everyone seemed to want
to take down Fiona Bruce yeah I mean
they make it impossible for people to
exist in public life anyone who knows
what a proper journalist's job is knows
that they have to give the other side of
the story but remain impartial as best
you know it exactly and that she didn't
pass any judgment she didn't say this is
right or wrong this person this the
person that she was speaking to called
him a wife beat alive on that nobody
said anything in defense of of Stanley
Johnson or not in defense of him but
somehow she reading a legal statement
which actually protects the BBC from
Liberal lawsuits yes somehow that makes
her the enemy and I think these people
don't understand they make it very
difficult for anyone to exist in public
life because they hold people to
ridiculous standards I think people are
going to take down Fiona Bruce over
something like this nobody is safe from
this absolutely nobody is safe and then
that's when people feel more
incentivized to be incendiary because
they said if I can't get away from it I
might will just play that game and then
you raise tensions because people feel
the need to just play fire with fire and
there is a kind of Glee isn't there we
saw it with Gary deniker as well from
people on the right and if it had been
if lineker had been supporting you know
being a right-wing commentator
presenting sport who just saves Matt
Leticia right give him the other side I
think it would have been all the people
defending the liquor would have been
paying for his blood so it works both
ways this this mob mentality but linnica
the Glee with which conservative MPS and
conservative pundits and so on would
were trying to destroy his career they'd
have a hard time doing that it was sort
of you know painful to watch in a
Democratic Society I felt painful to
watch someone being so
self-righteously condemned for his
opinion when all he was trying to do
albeit I think in a misguided way the
way he phrased this all he was trying to
do was stand up for refugees that was
his crime all that Fiona Bruce was
trying to do was was get some balance in
the middle of a debate because that's
her job as the moderator of question
type just to make sure there's always a
right of reply if someone's not there to
a serious allegation that's made we're
in a situation now where the children
are in charge they're no adults in the
room so whenever someone feels offended
or they feel slighted or they don't
agree with someone they happen to have
the loudest voice and we have to go in
the direction that they they want to go
in and the inmates are running the
Asylum because I don't agree with with
what Gary lineker said but I in this in
the spirit of free speech which
conservatives ironically Champion yeah I
didn't believe he should have lost his
job or even should have been taken off
there and with Fiona Bruce this is even
more ridiculous because there was no
offense given quite frankly these people
are making it impossible for rational
spaces where people can speak freely to
exist and that's going to have a
detrimental effect right and I think um
Rachel just coming back to you I do
think that the person who should be held
accountable is surely Stanley Johnson
right when he gives interviews again now
he should be vigorously pressed on this
by journalists about exactly what the
truth is and he should be made to say
his version of events on the record and
rightly challenged I mean that to me
seems to be who should be targeted in
this way not Fiona Bruce
I absolutely agree with you pierce
because what has happened now we've
taken the focus off the perpetrator you
know whether it was a one-off or not
um as Fiona said and she would have
known she knows about domestic abuse and
perpetrators um and it's not just a
one-off so what's happened there in the
media we've taken the focus off the
perpetrator as per usual and focusing on
something else which is Fiona and like I
said I support Fiona and I know she
would not have said that um through her
own uh opinion that is just something
she had to say oh and also can I just
say as well you know you said about the
government
shame on like Fiona no shame on the
government when they don't sort their
magistrates and judges Aid in court when
I had to go to a victim last week
because she'd been strangled by her
perpetrator so ferociously her neck was
black but yet he walked from court
because the magistrate knew nothing
really about domestic abuse and violence
and give him a 12-month custodial
sentence suspended for two years so
shame on the government there well I'm
I'm equally as angry as you about that
as I was about the poor boy that we
interviewed yesterday who was wrongly
tarnished as being a rapist by a total
fantasist and she ends up getting an
eight-year sentence for ruining so many
lives he would have got 22 years his
lawyers had told him had he been found
guilty of all the charges against him
Larissa this wider issue of canceled
culture there is a feeling that the woke
left and I I think you identify as one
um but you can correct me if you like
um that the woke left take a sort of
weird Glee
in canceling people whose views you
don't share do you think that's right
and do you think it's healthy for a
democracy
no I don't understand stand where this
idea that pencil culture is somehow
aligned with the left exists when so
many leftists are supportive of
transformative Justice which is all
about taking time for education for
relearning for unlearning things
um and then coming back into things and
that's why when we're saying that Fiona
Bruce has taken a step back maybe she
took a minute to think why have I
received so much backlash who may I have
harmed or perhaps not no and haven't so
you're told by Refuge she she couldn't
be an ambassador anymore that's what
happens what grounds are you saying that
is I know that for a fact
you know sorry can you bring a sauce or
something I'm just telling you it's true
so what's the point telling you my Souls
no I'm not telling you myself but I can
tell you that's what that is what
happened
okay so the purpose that's what happened
but per the public reports in the news
about what happened uh Fiona Bruce has
uh has decided to take a step back yeah
let me tell you Larissa I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna teach you how to suck
journalistic eggs this formative stage
of your burgeoning career however every
time a public figure involved in the
Scandal says they've suddenly decided to
take a step back it's very rarely their
idea it's usually somebody else's name
and if you'd like to be less patronizing
that would be far provided to Extended
violence in this in this segment so I
apologize for being patented
I think this is an opportunity for
Learning and growth yeah so I think it
could be a positive thing it's not about
taking it with Glee It's about seeing
the bright side of this I would love to
see the bright side uh good to talk to
you Larissa thank you very much indeed
Rachel thank you very much